pour économiser l'épicerie il y a pas de
miracle ça prend du temps et de
l'organisation on va partager avec vous
des trucs certains que vous connaissez
déjà mais pourquoi pas tout le monde
veut économiser quelques dollars
d'abord l'inventaire on ouvre les portes
fouillez partout faire des rotations
dans le frigo le congélo et dans le
garde-manger et faire le constat de ce
qu'on a déjà toutes les portes ça évite
le gaspillage on achète rien en double
donc on économise déjà là on a presque
un repas et oui consultez les
circulaires ça fonctionne encore que ce
soit papier ou en ligne moi ce que
j'aime bien c'est m'inspirer des
spéciaux pour préparer mes menus de la
semaine et on est à la période des
récoltes les fruits les légumes sont
vraiment pas cher c'est le temps de
faire des provisions et manger avant
d'aller à l'épicerie c'est toujours un
bon truc
le défi sans tenir à sa liste et éviter
certaines rangées
attention au four abais par exemple ce
pot de cornichons en solde revient plus
cher que celui au prix régulier c'est
important de regarder les petits
caractères même sur les étiquettes ici
vous allez voir on a le prix au 100 ml
et si vous avez pas l'information allez
sur le site de SOS Cuisine au calcul
tout pour vous pas besoin d'être bon en
maths
par exemple sur le site internet ou
l'application pour Android vous
trouverez une section où l'on offre un
comparateur de rabais des circulaires en
cours et un évaluateur de coûts deux
outils qui permettent de savoir si vous
payez le juste prix
peu importe le prix ou les spéciaux
parfois c'est le choix personnel qui va
l'emporter parfois faut faire des
compromis
connaissez-vous les imbattables
bonjour ici il y a un imbattable pour ça
ici est-ce que vous pouvez l'appliquer
ce principe s'applique aussi ailleurs
vous trouvez un produit moins cher dans
une grande chaîne avec preuve certaines
épiceries vous l'offrent au même prix
des invataires peuvent me faire souvent
environ 30 dollars quant aux cartes
fidélité si vous voulez que ça soit
payant rendu à la caisse il faut être
fidèle à une seule chaîne
dans la plupart des chaînes de
supermarchés des commerces de quartier
vous allez trouver ce type de frigo vous
téléchargez l'application qui est reliée
vous réservez à un item et vous payez en
ligne souvent avec des rabais de plus de
50%. ça évite le gaspillage alimentaire
et ça permet d'économiser
là on est de retour on a fait de bonnes
économies mais c'est pas fini
on vous a demandé de faire part de vos
trucs pour économiser sur nos réseaux
sociaux merci de l'avoir fait parce
qu'en effet on les a testé et ça
fonctionne un demi truc préféré
réorganisé mon frigo pour être sûr que
tous les aliments qui seront bientôt
périmés soient vraiment visibles aussi
changer les emballages permet d'étirer
la durée de vie des aliments mais faire
cela ça prend un certain temps oui il
faut s'en tenir à sa liste mais il faut
aussi garder l'oeil ouvert parce que
parfois en succursale il y a des
spéciaux qui valent vraiment la peine
ici un poulet spécial du gérant deux
pour 10 dollars puis on va faire pas mal
de ménage avec
ça ici c'est pas mon compost c'est des
retards de légumes puis je vais les
utiliser pour faire du bouillon et les
femmes de carottes ça va pas aux
poubelles je peux les faire sécher les
manger en pesto ou encore en salade les
tomates sont pas chères cette semaine
mais j'ai pas le temps de les cuisiner
tout de suite allez hop au congélo je
vais pouvoir les ressortir cet hiver
pour faire des soupes des Chili des
sauces et puis après avoir fait des
listes après avoir comparé les prix
après avoir cuisiné nettoyer vos légumes
organiser votre frigo vos armoires il
faut aussi se gâter